Hello, welcome to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A.
My name is Angela Lom Mccang. I'm glad
that you have tuned in. You are going to
be blessed. What you need is the word of
God. Bring that, take that with you
right now. We are going to open these
sacred pages of this book and we're
going to glean. We're going to learn.
We're going to grow. So, we are so
blessed once again that you've tuned in.
Thank you for joining us each week to
this for this wonderful program. I am
always blessed whenever I am here
learning the word of God. My husband and
I love opening up the word of God. We
study this book. It's our life. It's our
guide that's will lead us to eternity.
>> Amen. Anyway, today we have a wonderful
panel, three pastors that are here with
us today, and I'd like to introduce each
one. Right in front of me is the love of
my life, Pastor John Lang. Hi, sweetie.
>> Good to be with you, honey. Always a
blessing to be on the program with you,
but even more than that, to study God's
word together.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Pastor Ryan Johnson, how are you
today? I'm doing just fine and thank you
so much for those words because I
totally agree. This is a blessing for us
and we pray that it is a blessing for
you as well. When we get a chance to get
together and study the word, I always
leave a little bit higher than I was
when I came in.
>> Amen. Amen. Pastor Dy,
>> it's a blessing to be here and uh when
we participate in this program, it's
always a growing learning experience.
So, we want to thank everyone for
sending their questions. It really is uh
stimulating, let's say, to study God's
word.
>> Thank you, Pastor NZ. Gentlemen, well,
maybe you have a question that you would
like to send in. You can email us at
bibleqa3abn.tv
or you can text us at 6182283975
or Instagram at 3abn_official.
All right. Well, let's go to the Lord in
prayer. Pastor John, would you open with
prayer, please?
>> Sure. Loving Father in heaven, every
time we open the Bible, we pray that
your Holy Spirit opens our hearts and
opens our minds. Speak to us so that
when we speak to the people, we know
that there's an unbroken connection
between heaven and what is being said.
>> And may the glory and the honor go to
you alone. We pray in Jesus name.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. We always go to the word of God
through prayer as so we are thankful.
Anyway, let's start with our first
question. Pastor John,
>> this is from Lenora in North Carolina
and she says she her question is I know
that Jesus has never sinned. So my
question is, how is it that we are born
sinners and yet Jesus was born of a
woman and came as we did but wasn't
considered a sinner at birth as we are.
>> Okay, thank you so much. Well, let me
just dive right into it. There's a
difference between sinner and sin. Now,
sin is the nature and sins are the acts
of transgression against God's law.
>> Let me show the difference. Jesus took
on the nature that Adam transferred to
all humanity. Remember, he was born
through Mary. So when the Bible says
born of a woman, born under the law, it
didn't just mean born under the Jewish
law or the ten commandments, but it
meant born under the law of sin and
death. He had to become what we are so
that we could become what he is. Notice
1 Corinthians 15:22. What happened as a
result of Adam's sin? For as in Adam all
die, even so in Christ all shall be made
alive. Why? As in Adam all die. That's
the sin nature. But notice the sins now.
1 John 3:4, whoever commits sin also
transgresses the law. For sin is the
transgression of the law. One is the
nature, one is the act. Jesus took on
the nature, but he never perpetrated the
act. That's the difference. And here's
the reason why he had to. You see, it
was necessary for Jesus to take on our
nature so he can conquer our nature and
gain the victory for us. Hebrews 2:14.
>> In as much then as the children have
partaken of flesh and blood, he himself
likewise get it shared in the same that
through death he might destroy him who
had the power of death that is the
devil. So he shared in our nature to
become victorious over that. And as a
result of his victory over that, then
now he can give to us what we don't have
because of our fallen nature. Here's the
reasons I'm going to read. First of So
Jesus came not only the to atone for our
sins, but he also came to change our
nature. Look at the two in comparison.
John 1:29, behold the lamb of God that
takes away the sin of the world. That's
the nature, the broken relationship.
>> But Matthew 1:21,
>> he shall save his people from their
sins. That's the transgressive acts
>> to have the nature doesn't mean you have
to permit the act. And Jesus was the
evidence of that in his life. We are
condemned by sin but we are not
condemned to sin. That nature that Jesus
took on was the condemning nature of
Adam. He took that nature to the cross
and was victorious over it. So what the
Bible says what the law could not do in
that it was weak through the flesh.
Romans 8:3 God did by sending his own
son in the likeness of sinful flesh on
account of sin he condemned sin in the
flesh 2 Corinthians 5:21 he made him who
knew no sin to be sin for us that we
might become the righteousness of God in
him thereby conquering that sin nature
then he can do what 1 Corinthians 15:57
says
but thanks be to God who gives us the
victory through our Lord Lord Jesus
Christ. So Jesus wasn't born a with the
with sinful acts. We received Adam's
broken nature which Jesus conquered at
the cross and gave us his victory.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Thank you. And we know in Hebrews
4:15, he was tempted at all points
>> just like we are.
>> What did he sin?
>> Yet without sin.
>> Thank you for that, honey. Yes.
Wonderful example. Amen.
>> Yes. Thank you, sweetie. Okay, Pastor
Johnson.
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> Here's your question.
If they were all sleeping in the garden
of Gethsemane, how do we know what Jesus
prayed? This is from Christine in
Florida.
>> Thank you so much, Sister Christina. Uh,
this is a great question because it
gives us an opportunity to see how the
Holy Spirit was working as um people
were writing the accounts of the Bible,
our scriptures. Well, the question is
about Gethsemane. And for those of you
who are not familiar, let's just take a
little look here. Um Jesus is nearing
the end of his earthly ministry, the
shadow of the cross stretching over the
savior. And you find that the gospels
all coalesce at this point. You have
what we call the last supper. And after
that, Christ goes to pray in the garden
that is called Gethsemane. Now the
gospel of John doesn't go into a lot of
detail there, but Matthew, Mark, and
Luke really do. After Gethsemane, Christ
is arrested right there in the garden
and then the other things that lead to
the cross take place. This is worth
studying
>> because I believe this is just me that
this was when the earth was hanging in
the balance humanity right here because
you can read this and I like the version
of Matthew Matthew 26:36.
It says, "Then cometh Jesus with them to
a place called Gethsemane. And he says
to the disciples, sit here and pray with
me." And the disciples, and this is what
sister Christine was talking about, fall
asleep rather than pray with the master.
But if you look in there, Christ asks
this question, if it be possible, let
this cup pass. And also as Christ is
being arrested, he then says, "Don't you
know that if I wanted to, I could call
upon 12 legions of angels and the father
would send them." What if he had? But it
was God's will that we be saved. Don't
let anybody tell you it is not God's
will that you be saved. This here is
proof. Nevertheless, as you read in the
narrative, the disciples were asleep
while Christ was praying. Yet, the
account is given here. I'm going to go
one further. Sister Lomma King, this is
Matthew's account that I'm talking
about. Matthew wasn't there at all.
>> No,
>> it was who were who were the disciples
that went with Christ?
>> Peter, James, and John. And before we
take a simple look to answer this
question, I think I'm going to make it
even worse. This is from the book of
Hebrews. And listen to what it says in
Hebrews 5:5. So also Christ glorified
not himself to be made an high priest,
but he that said unto him, "Thou art my
son. Today have I begotten thee. And
look at this. It says, "Who in the days
of his flesh when he had offered up
prayers and supplication with strong
crying and tears unto him that was able
to save him from death." This is
Hebrews. And the author of Hebrews was
certainly not there yet. Gethsemane is
being referenced. How is that? And I've
decided we will make a very simple
answer to that by reading from the book
of Revelation chapter 1. And I'm going
to read verse 11. God says to John, "I
am Alpha and Omega, the first and the
last. What thou seeest write in a book."
>> Exactly.
>> The Holy Ghost will show
>> exactly
>> as the authors write. And the Holy Ghost
is with you as you read. How could Ellen
White see things of the end? And she is
not there. That's right.
>> That is proof of the power of the Holy
Ghost.
>> Amen. Praise God. I just felt like I was
at church.
>> Praise God.
>> That was beautiful. Thank you, pastor.
Okay, Pastor Dy,
how would you define spiritual apathy?
How would you recognize it? How would
one combat it in addition to the help of
the Holy Spirit? This is from Jackie in
Georgia.
Well, thank you Jackie for the question
and this is uh very interesting that
you're asking because uh you may go to
any church and you'll find this
spiritual apathy. So how would you
define it? It can be uh something that
there's very little interest or lack of
interest in spiritual things and
unfortunately
um we have to consider that there's a
source of uh to this and sometimes uh we
see that the devil works on our weak
points and little by little leads us
astray.
>> Now the Bible tells us that is by their
fruits you will know them. Mhm.
>> So a person that is showing very little
interest in spiritual things are not
going to be showing the fruits of the
spirit. They're not going to show love
for others. They're not going to show
interest in spiritual things. Uh you
have Wednesday night prayer meeting.
They're not there. Uh this afternoon
we're going to go uh to a nursing home
and sing some songs. They are not there.
>> Uh we're going to do a Bible study at
300 p.m. on Saturday. They are not
there. And so, uh, spiritual apathy is a
dangerous dangerous thing. So, I would
encourage you to consider,
um, Revelation chapter 3 because it
seems to have a little bit of this here
in the Leodysian church. I'm going to
read several verses here beginning in
Revelation 3:14 and onward. And to the
angel, the church of Leodysians, write
these things, says the, amen, the
faithful and true witness, the beginning
of the creation of God. I know your
works that you are neither cold nor hot.
I could wish you were cold or hot. So
then be because you are lukewarm and
neither cold nor hot, I will vomit you
out of my mouth. This is a description
pretty much of spiritual apathy. Because
you say I am rich and have become
wealthy, have need of nothing, and do
not know that you are wretched and
miserable, poor, blind and naked. Now
here is how you combat this. I counsel
you to buy from me gold refined in the
fire that you may be rich and white
garments that you may be clothed that
the shame of your nakedness may not be
revealed and anoint your eyes with eyes
have that you may see. As many as I
love, I rebuke and chasen. Therefore, be
zealous and repent. Behold, I stand at
the door and knock. If anyone hears my
voice and opens the door, I will come
into him and dine with him and he with
me. This is including all of us. Jesus
is knocking at the door of our heart.
Whether you are cold or hot, every
single person has the blessing of Jesus
knocking at their door. Amen.
>> So how do you combat this thing
>> is by looking unto Jesus, the author and
finisher of our faith. Maintaining a
close relationship with him, you will
not have the danger of falling into
spiritual apathy.
>> Right?
>> Read the Bible, study. When there are
meetings at church, it's within your
means. go and participate and be active
in singing praises to God and then you
will see that this will not be a problem
for you.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. It's a serious thing that
spiritual apathy, isn't it?
>> Sneak up on you.
>> Yes. Yes. You got to be in prayer and in
the word of God. And as you said, sing
songs, sing praises. Yeah. And go to uh
activities, church activities. Get
involved. Thank you for that. Okay,
Pastor John.
What did Jesus mean in Mark 12 24-27?
Is he saying that Abraham, Isaac, and
Jacob are now alive? This is from
Tashana in Pennsylvania.
>> Okay. Well, let me just go ahead and
read Mark 12:4 to 27.
>> Jesus answered and said to them, "Are
you not therefore mistaken because you
do not know the scriptures nor the power
of God? For when they rise from the
dead, they neither marry nor are given
in marriage, but are like angels in
heaven. But concerning the dead that
they rise, have you not read in the book
of Moses in the burning of in the
burning bush passage how God spoke to
him saying, "I am the God of Abraham,
the God of Isaac, and the God of Jacob.
He is not the God of the dead, but the
God of the living. You are therefore
greatly mistaken." The context here was
the Sadducees, a Jewish sect, they
denied the validity of the resurrection.
You can read that in Acts chapter 23 and
verse 8. So therefore, what they did,
they formulated a trick question about
marriage to try to challenge Jesus about
the resurrection. This was not about the
woman being married. They wanted to see
what his answer was going to be about
the resurrection. And you can read those
in verses 18 to 23 of Ma of Mark 12.
So this hypothetical story about the
woman marrying seven brothers was
designed to mock the resurrection
doctrine. What did Jesus say? He said
two things. They misunderstand
scripture. Secondly, and they
underestimate the power of God. That's
why verse 24 said, "Are you not
therefore mistaken?" So what is what is
actually the context of this? What was
Jesus saying? First of all, when he
said, "I'm not the God of the dead." You
know what he meant by that? He wasn't
speaking about the first death because
all the prophets he referred to were
already dead.
>> Yeah.
>> Why would he say, "I'm not the God of
the dead." When he said, "I'm the God of
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob." They're
already dead.
>> He was addressing the resurrection
factor
>> because those who come forth in the
resurrection are asleep. The Christian
doctrine is sleep. those who really die.
As he said to John, as he said to Mary
and Martha about the death of Lazarus,
he who lives and believes in me shall
never die. And people think, well, we
don't really die. No, he talked about
he's talking about the second death.
Revelation 20 and verse 6. So when he
said he's not the God of the dead, he's
talking about the second death, which
the Pharisees would stay far away from
because they didn't believe in the
resurrection at all. Revelation 20 and:e
6, blessed and holy is he who has part
in the first resurrection over such the
second death has no power. That's the
death Jesus talked about when he says
I'm not the God of the dead. If you're
in the second resurrection, I'm not your
God. I'm the God of those who will be in
the first resurrection. That's why he
referred to Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob.
And then he says in 1 Thessalonians
4:15, for this we say to you by the word
of the Lord that we who are alive and
remain until the coming of the Lord will
by no means precede those who are
asleep. So he was saying to the Jews now
okay you're denying the resurrection but
there is a resurrection and those who
are sleeping in Jesus will come forth in
the first resurrection. This is not
about marriage. This is about the
reality of the fact that resurrection is
sure.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Amen. Thank you for that.
>> Okay, Pastor Johnson,
>> this is an interesting question.
>> Why do I feel so worthless and without
purpose? I love the Lord.
I just don't feel that God loves me.
>> This is from Mike in Michigan.
>> Hey, Mike, and God be with you.
>> You began that question with why. And I
don't have an answer, but I know who has
the answers.
>> In fact, before we get into this, if you
are really struggling with something,
it's okay to talk to somebody. And I'd
like to do more than just say that. This
number 618-627-4651
extension 802. That's our pastoral
department. You go ahead and call and
talk and pray with somebody. Prayer
works. There are people who have walked
where you are walking and the God who
delivered them can deliver you.
>> But you asked about worth and you asked
about purpose. I would like to make a
biblical argument showing the worth that
God has on you. Well, we're going to
begin in the first epistle of Peter and
listen to what the Bible says. We're
going to first Peter 8 1 18. It says,
"For as much as ye know that ye were not
redeemed, that's ransomed, paid h paid
for, with corruptible things, you're not
redeemed with silver and gold." It says
verse 19, but with the precious blood of
Christ as of a lamb without blemish and
without spot. That word precious in the
Greek. Timios means valuable means
costly. Christ life is immeasurably
valuable. Can we all agree with that?
>> Amen.
>> All right. Now, making our argument,
let's go to Romans. I'm going to read
chapter 5 and verse 8. It says, "But God
commendeth his love toward us in that
while we were yet sinners, Christ died
for us. Christ gave his life for us.
Christ paid for us with his life. And if
Christ's life is immeasurably valuable
and he paid for us with his life, value
conferred, my friend, you are
immeasurably valuable. And I just like
to stop and say this is why you can't
let anybody, no atheist convince you to
walk away from God because they try to
take away the value that Christ has
bestowed upon us. You are valuable, my
friend. You are because of Jesus Christ.
You hang on to Jesus as Christ is
hanging on to you. But there was another
part of that question, wasn't it?
>> You asked about your purpose. And I I
get this a lot and I' I've asked that a
lot about my own life. What is my
purpose, Lord? What's my purpose?
Father, what's my purpose? And then I
ran into Romans chapter 8 verse 28. And
I want you to hear this. This is one
that you've heard many times. It says,
"And we know that all things work
together for good to them that love God,
to them that are called according to his
purpose. Oh, have mercy." I believe that
we will find change when we stop
praying, "Lord, what's my purpose?" and
begin to say, "Lord, what's your purpose
for me?" And he will show you. So go
with God, my brother, you valuable
brother. Call that number and be
encouraged.
>> Amen. Amen. And they are not worthless,
are they? None of God's preachers.
>> None of us are worthless. Royal
priesthood.
>> We are a royal priesthood. Thank you.
Years ago, um Kathy in Antioch,
California used to say, "God doesn't
make junk." And I never forgot that.
Remember, you are not junk. You are
bought with a price. You are precious.
>> So, thank you so much. All right, Pastor
Denzy.
Who was the father of Cain and Abel?
>> I don't find them listed in the
genealogy of Adam according to Genesis
5:3 and 4. Also 1 Chronicles 1 verse 1
to4. This is from Lewis in New York.
>> Thank you Lewis. It's a very interesting
question
>> and we have to go to the word of God and
and see what the Bible tells us
concerning this. And so I point you to
Genesis chapter 4 beginning in verse one
and it says, "Now Adam
knew Eve his wife and she conceived and
bore Cain and said, "I have acquired a
man from the Lord." So it is very clear
here in Acts chap I in Genesis chapter 4
that the father of Cain is Adam. Now
verse two says, "Then she bore again
this time his brother Abel." Now Abel
was a keeper of sheep but Cain was a
tiller of the ground. So Adam is the the
father of Cain and Abel. Now the
question arises well why is he not
mentioned in the genealogy that um we
see in Genesis chapter 5. And so there's
a reason for this and that is because
the genealogies the main purpose of the
genealogies is to help us understand the
lineage the genealogy of Jesus Christ
and only the firstborn son is mentioned.
You will notice that as you look through
Genesis chapter 5 and and um the other
book you mentioned I will get to that in
a moment um only the first son is
mentioned by name. The others are just
uh in essence it says and he had many
sons and daughters. Let's go ahead and
go to Genesis chapter 5. This is the
book of the genealogy of Adam. In the
day that God created man, he made him in
the likeness of God. He created male and
female and blessed them and called them
mankind in the day they were created.
And Adam lived
130 years and begott a son in his own
likeness after his own image and named
him Seth.
So, isn't it curious that the Lord said
to Adam and Eve, "Be fruitful and
multiply, and they're going to wait 130
years to have children." No, they had
Cain and Abel first. Uh, but because
Cain killed Abel, someone was supposed
to take the place of Cain as the
firstborn to have the g the privilege of
being in the genealogy of Jesus. And so,
this is why Seth was born and this is
why he is named here. And notice what it
says here in Genesis chapter 5:4. After
he begot Seth, the days of Adam were 800
years, and he had sons and daughters.
They're not all named. Imagine how long
uh the Bible would be if all the sons
and daughters would be named in uh of
all of the people that had sons and
daughters that are in the genealogy of
Jesus. So, the other book you mentioned
is the book of 1 Chronicles. The same
thing happens if you keep reading in
Genesis 5 and 1 Chronicles chapter 1,
you will notice that they just named the
first son as the firstborn and then it
says sons and daughters.
>> Thank you. Well, maybe you've just tuned
in and you'd like to send a question in.
You can do so by emailing us at
bibleqa3abn.tv
TV or you can send us a text by texting
at 618-2283975.
Maybe you're an Instagram person. You
can send that in by at 3ABN
official. Thank you. All right, Pastor
John. In Genesis, was the serpent
created with power of choice and reason?
If not, why biblically was it cursed by
God the same as Adam and Eve? If so,
wouldn't that not make the serpent the
first sinner on earth? This is from Gary
in Oregon.
>> Okay. Well, Gary, according to Genesis
3:1, let's look at the context of the
story. Animals are not created with
moral reasoning like God has created us.
We are free moral agents. Now, they do
make choices whether to eat you or not
to eat you. You know, that's the choice
that they make. And depend depending on
what jungle you're in, they they make
decisions about where to lay their eggs
and things like that. But the moral the
moral uh abilities that we have, choice
or not choice, uh that's right or that's
wrong. They don't have that qual
quality. So, the Bible talked about the
context of what happened here. And let
me just kind of go forward to come back
here. The serpent today throughout all
of human history after the fall of
humanity after that garden uh experience
the devil decided to possessed the
serpent.
>> The serpent didn't say, "Hey, I'd be
glad to help you out." He possessed the
serpent. That's why the Bible uses the
phrase when the word there cunning in
Hebrew mean shrewd or subtle. But it
doesn't mean the serpent had moral
reasoning or free moral agency to say to
the devil, "Hey, I' I'd be glad to help
you out." No, Satan possessed him.
>> And Genesis 3:1 now says, "Now the
serpent was more cunning than any beast
of the field which the Lord God had
made." Now, where do you think he got
that cunningness from? That was a that
was a quality that Satan himself had.
that subtle quality that he used to
persuade one-third of the angels that
sinned and followed him by the multitude
of his trading. He was cunning to trade
uh darkness for light and uh evil for
good. He was cunning in his deception
about who God really is in the
character. But he did the same thing in
the earth. He saw the serpent. And why
did he choose that one? Now, why would
it be a curse for the serpent to uh to
be when we see the serpents now they're
walking on their belly? Because prior to
that, serpents were beings of dazzling
brightness. They actually flew. They had
wings. The curse that was now handed
down to the serpent was a reminder of
God's dealing with Satan himself. That's
why Revelation 12 calls him that serpent
of old called the devil and Satan. And
you also find so from that day on,
that's why people are naturally
inherently afraid of serpents. It could
be a a gardis serpent that's a little
green guy that's not going to bother you
all the way to a boa constrictor or a
python that really would kill you or a
black mamba. But the Bible doesn't give
the serpent the category of being the
first sinner. The Bible talks about Eve
being deceived. Now Eve could be fallen
into the category of the first sinner,
but her personal sin was distrust of
God. But Adam giving given the dominion
of the earth was the one that opened the
door. Romans 5:12, therefore by one man
sin entered the world, and death through
sin, and thus death spread to all men.
So the first sinner on earth was Adam.
Satan sinned in heaven and carried his
wares to the earth. And because of
Adam's sin, it passed on all of us.
>> Thank you, Pastor John. Okay, Pastor
Johnson, here's an interesting question.
As a church, we speak strongly against
being unequally yolked, especially in
marriage. Second Corinthians 6:14-16
and Deuteronomy 7:3-4. Yet in Esther's
case, she married a heathen king
>> and God used it to save his people. Does
God allow his law to be broken to
accomplish his purpose? This is from
Bern Bernard in Jamaica.
>> Thank you so much, Sister Lom Kang. Wow,
there's a lot to cover in this one. We
have the law of God. We have the
testimony of Esther. And yes, we have
this admonishment that we should not be
unequally yolked. And we do talk about a
lot in a lot in the church. Pastor Lang
and I were talking earlier about how
sometimes it is not used properly. But
before we look at the text, let's do a
little bit of history because some of
you may not be familiar with the
metaphor of not being equally yolked. So
back in the day and today in certain
countries when they're plowing the
field, what they would do is they would
get two very strong beasts of burden.
Often it' be two oxen and they'll put
them side by side and they have these
beasts pull the plow. And you want to
have straight nice straight narrow lines
through the field. Sometimes the farmer
is riding, sometimes the farmer is
behind the plow. But when you choose the
animals that are going to be doing this
pulling, you want them to be what's
called equally yolked. If you have an
animal that has a tendency to disobey,
say the farmer says go this way and one
animal's going this way and the other
one veers off, you are not going to stay
on the straight and narrow. You are
going to curve to the right or to the
left, whatever the case may be. Now that
bar that connects the two animals is
called the yoke. And so if the animals
are unequally yolked, you do not get a
staying on the straight and narrow. That
is my third time saying it. I believe it
is clear now what is meant when it says
we should not be unequally yolked. So
let's have a look in 2 Corinthians
chapter 6:14. Here's the text. It says,
"But ye not unequally yolked. Be not
unequally yolked together with
unbelievers." That's a pistol. That's
those who are unconvinced or unfaithful.
For what fellowship hath righteousness,
with unrighteousness, and what communion
hath light with darkness? These examples
of being unequally yolked, light being
yolked with darkness, um unrighteousness
being yolked with righteousness. We
don't want that because the objective is
to avoid any connection that would cause
us to go astray. Now we do apply this to
marriage. But if you read there in the
text, Paul talks about it from an even
larger view. The church for example, the
early church in those days was
surrounded by idolatrous idolatrous
cultures. He's saying do not connect
with people that may cause you to go
astray. Even the church today, we are
told not to go into business and
enterprise with entities that may cause
the church to go astray. But as far as
marriage is concerned,
>> here's something interesting. I have
counseledled Sabbathkeeping people,
>> both of them, and they were not equally
yolked. I'm just telling the truth. One
was wanting to stay on the straight and
narrow, keep the commandments of God,
and the other was all about that thug
life. So, we have to be careful how we
ascribe it. The objective is to stay
attuned with God. Nevertheless, it does
say in Deuteronomy chapter 7 and you can
read that in verse one, verse three and
verse four, that we are not to be
unequally yolked. But that is not, and
now we come to the law. That is not the
decalogue. That is Mosaic law. It is
good counsel given to the children of
Israel who did struggle with idolatry.
So it is not breaking the decalogue. But
you referenced Esther who was indeed wed
to a person that was not of the Jewish
culture. It was a Persian. But I want to
read you something. This is from the
book of Esther. And here's chapter 2
verse two. It says, "Then said the
king's servants that ministered unto
him, let there be fair young virgins
sought for the king, and let the king
appoint officers in all the provinces of
his kingdom, that they may gather
together all the fair young virgins."
Esther did not court the king. She was
not betrod to the king. She was taken
because she was pretty. This is a
different situation. This is God taking
a messed up situation and using it for
the good of his people. Isn't it
wonderful that God will do that?
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> Beautiful. Thank you for that. And you
could be of the same religion and be
unequally yolked also.
>> That's right.
>> We've seen that because you can say,
"Oh, yeah. I love the Lord, but they are
going on different roads when we have
counseledled many couples." Thank you
for that, pastor. All right, Pastor
Denzy. This is from someone in India.
I didn't meet my grandfather, but when I
was 11 years old, I saw a tall man near
my house.
>> Could this be that God showed me my
grandfather
as an angel?
>> That's a very good question. And I want
to
think for a moment about uh what this
may mean. Uh there are people that
believe that their dead relatives can
come back to them. There are people that
believe that their dead relatives
eventually become angels. But the Bible
doesn't teach that. Uh let's take a look
at Ecclesiastes chapter 9 uh beginning
in verse 5. It says, "For the living
know that they will die, but the dead
know nothing, and they have no more
reward, for the memory of them is
forgotten. also their love, their hatred
and their envy have now perished. Never
more will they have a share in anything
done under the sun. So unfortunately
your grandfather cannot really visit you
or even come in the form of an angel
because the Bible teaches that he is in
the grave. He's in the grave until the
time for of the resurrection. And Jesus
talks about the resurrection in uh a few
places, but the the one that I want to
go to is John chapter 5. In John chapter
5, uh beginning in verse 28, we have the
following words. Do not marvel at this,
for the hour is coming in which all who
are in the grace will hear his voice.
Notice it says the hour is coming. So
there's a point in time when that hour
comes and that is when Jesus Christ
returns. And it says and and come for
I'm sorry do not marvel at this for the
hour is coming in which all who are in
the grace will hear his voice. How many?
All will hear his voice. And it says and
come forth those who have done good to
the resurrection of life and those who
have done evil to the resurrection of
condemnation. As you consider the Bible,
you will notice that the resurrection of
life is when Jesus returns. You can go
to 1 Thessalonians chapter 4 and read
about that there. But uh the
resurrection of condemnation, that is a
resurrection that takes place after
1,000 years as you see revealed in
Revelation chapter 20. So when you see
these verses, so when you study this
out, you will notice that uh when for
example, there are some people that have
heard things like when I die, I'm going
to come back and visit you as a ghost,
you know, and and this this is just not
possible because the Bible says that uh
the dead know nothing and they have no
participation in anything done under the
sun. You can rest peacefully. I was
passing a grave uh the other day as I
was driving and I said, "Wow, that's one
of the most peaceful places on the
earth." Yet, people are afraid to walk,
you know, through a cemetery because
they think they're going to be, you
know, a ghost is coming or somebody
coming from the dead is going to grab
them or something. But it's one of the
most peaceful places in the world.
Everybody is in the grave. And so, uh,
no, your your grandfather did not appear
as an angel. He's waiting in the grave.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you for that. M not
well recently we were at the Arlington
National Cemetery and it had a little
sign to be reverent and all that but
they don't know anything.
>> That's right.
>> They are resting in the grave. Thank you
so much.
>> Okay, Pastor John. In 1 Corinthians
13:1, the scriptures say, "If I speak in
the tongues of men and of angels, the
tongues of men are the languages between
different nations which can be
interpreted."
But I don't believe any of us as humans
can interpret the tongues of angels.
What are the tongues of angels talked
about in this book? This is from Anthony
in Ohio.
>> Great. Great. I'll start with the
tongues of angels. Well, there are two
main things that Paul is addressing
here. And these are hyperboles.
First of all, when you read 1
Corinthians chapter 13, the verse verse
one, I'll just start with that one.
Though I speak with the tongues of men
and of angels, but have not love, I have
become like a sounding brass, a clinging
symbol. He's he this is an exaggerated
point because all through the book he
talked about having all knowledge, all
faith, give my body to be burned. He is
saying no matter what you do, even if
you had the most uh articulate
uh uh kind of language, if you could be
most eloquent, that's what he's in
essence saying here. So this is
hyperbolic language. You have some
examples in the Bible where angels did
speak. Genesis 19 and then also in the
book of Luke when the angel Gabriel came
to speak to Mary. And in both cases they
spoke in the language that was
understood by the people. There is not a
single scripture in the Bible not even
one remotely that describes an angelic
language. This has been used in the
arena of something called glosselia
where people are trying to give
foundation to this unintelligible
language but they have no foundation for
it and it's often called in some circles
well this is what came into America in
the 1920s in the Pentecostal movement
but that was inadequately applied
because if you look at Pentecost it was
not a day of of lack of intelligence it
was a day of expansion of intelligence
let's look at that in Acts chapter 2
6-11. When the Lord poured out his
spirit on these Galileans,
they were given an instant spiritual uh
injection to be able to accomplish what
the Lord gave them the responsibility to
do in the commission. Go therefore and
make disciples of all nations. Well, how
am I going to do that? I can only speak
Galilean. This is the only place I'm
from. Look at Acts chapter 2 6-11.
And when this sound occurred, the
multitude came together and were
confused because everyone heard them
speak in his own language right away. It
was not something unintelligible. It was
not an angelic language.
>> Then they were all amazed. Verse seven,
and marveled, saying to one another,
look, art not all these who speak
Galileans. I just made the point.
>> And how is it that we hear each in our
own language in which we were born? In
other words, the Galileans when I was
speaking, I could say today German, uh,
Portuguese,
uh, uh, uh, espanol, you know, exactly,
that's a different language. Well, when
I'm around Spanish people, I have a very
limited vocabulary. Leendiga, God bless
you. And, uh,
lependiga, God bless you all. So, those
are limited things, but the Lord puts
you in situations. And the day of
Pentecost was a situation where the Lord
had a responsibility for the Galileans.
And that is get the gospel to the rest
of the world. Let's look at the rest of
this. Verse 9 now describes all the
nations represented.
Parththeians and me and Elummites do
those dwelling in Mesopotamia, Judea and
Capadia, Pontius and Asia, Fajia,
Panthilia, Egypt and parts of Libya are
joining Sirene. visitors of Rome, both
Jews and proelites, as converts, cites
and Arabians, we hear them speak in our
own tongues the wonderful works of God.
So these were not unintell
unintelligible languages. But now
oftentimes the tongues of angels is used
to make people believe that if they pray
in this language, God hears them and the
devil cannot hear them. This is not
supported by scripture anywhere. If you
speak in your language, God understands
every language. And the devil cannot
prevent the prayer of a sincere saint in
the presence of God. So don't be pulled
in by something that has no scriptural
support.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. That's right. Thank you, honey.
Well, well done. Okay, here's our next
question, Pastor Ryan.
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> Do I need to name each sin when asking
for forgiveness?
>> What if I don't remember all of my sins?
What about sins I don't recognize as
sins? This is from Lee in Texas.
>> Thank you. First of all, the Lord will
not hold us accountable um for things
that we did not know or did not have an
opportunity to know. I want to put it
like that as well. That is not the God
we serve. But the Lord will shed light
into our lives as we work with him and
as we grow closer to him. I have heard
this before that it is good to be
specific when we ask for forgiveness.
But that is not for the Lord's benefit.
The Lord knows what we did. That is for
our benefit as we grow in him and as he
shows us the error of our ways. But why
don't we go to a promise? This is first
John 1:9. The word says if we confess,
come on preachers, our sins, he is
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness. That word confess is to
admit to agree. If we admit our sins,
the Bible says that God is faithful.
That means he is trustworthy. If we
confess, we can trust that he will
forgive us. We can have faith that he
will forgive us. I love the faithfulness
of God. Great is our sin. But the song
says, "Great is thy faithfulness, Lord,
unto me." So this is the promise. We
need to cling to the promise. But what
if we do not remember our sins or have
an opportunity to tabulate them? And now
I'm going to go to Luke
23. This is the crucifixion scene. And
you know where I'm going. We're going to
verse 39. And it says, "And one of the
male factors which were hanged railed on
Jesus, saying, If you be Christ, save
yourself and us. But the other answering
rebuked him, saying, Dust not thou fear
God? Seeing thou art in the same
condemnation?" Verse 42. And he, the
thief on the cross, said unto Jesus,
Lord, remember me when thou comest in
thy kingdom. And this is what Jesus said
to him. Verily I say unto thee today,
thou shalt be with me in paradise. I
love he put the remembering on Christ
have mercy. And he did not tabulate all
the sins and there hanging on the cross
probably didn't remember all the sins
but he reached out to Christ and it was
enough. So the objective here is not to
work our way into forgiveness as it were
by remembering each sin. But I'd like to
show you something else. This is the
139th Psalm. And look what it says in
verse 22. It says, "Search me, oh God,
>> and know my heart. Try me and know my
thoughts and see if there be any wicked
way in me and lead me in the way
everlasting." So this is a little crazy.
I don't know if I can do this. If you
are struggling to remember your sin, put
it on the Lord. Lord, search me and show
me and the Lord will do that. And my
friend, we will see you by his grace in
the kingdom.
>> Amen.
>> And your sins are what they're the Lord
won't remember them when you repent and
ask for forgiveness.
>> I love that, Bama. We're struggling to
remember and he will not remember.
>> He will not. He's God and he won't
remember. Thank you, Pastor. All right.
All right, Pastor Denzy.
I was told the original Bible is the
Ethiopian Bible and that some words in
the King James Bible are distorted. Is
that true? This is from Emily in
Florida.
>> Thank you, Emily. That's a very
interesting question.
>> And your question is concerning the
Ethiopian Bible. I would like to say to
you that the Ethiopian Bible is not an
original Bible. was not the original
Bible because the Ethiopian Bible is uh
a translation.
>> Uh the original Bible uh really are the
manuscripts written by the authors
themselves. Those are the original
>> and what the Ethiopian Bible is is a
translation. Uh really all all that we
have access to is really translations of
the Bible. There are many different
kinds of translations but the Ethiopian
Bible was written somewhere between the
fourth and sixth century and the Old
Testament of the Ethiopian Bible is a
translation from the Greek Septuagent of
the Old Testament. And then of course
the Greek manuscripts of the New
Testament were used to translate into
the uh guees or guees uh Ethiopian
language that was uh spoken somewhere
between the 1st and 7th century but
around the 10th century AD it ceased to
be a commonly spoken language even
though the uh Ethiopian church and
there's a church in Ethiopia that still
in their religious um activities use
that g language. So is it is it uh more
accurate that that's a difficult
question to answer because all of the
Bibles are translations. Now consider
this for a moment. Uh it is translated
into the G language. I don't speak G. I
don't none of us do. So if we would have
uh the opportunity to read, we would
need a translation into English. And
there are some apparently some
translations into English from the GS
language. Uh so here are some
differences. The King James version has
66 book books and the Ethiopian Bible
has around
81 to 88 books. Where who what are these
other books? uh those are apocryphal
books that the Protestant churches do
not accept as um let's call them
inspired as the other uh as the books
that are found in the Protestant Bible.
So there are books like the book of
Ezra, the uh some of these apocrypha
books, there's a list of them. I can't
remember how many maybe some of you do
16 about 20 of these different apocrypha
books. But I do want to say something
about
um the accuracy. The King James version
is a very accurate Bible. It is a
trustworthy Bible. And you said
something about that the words are
distorted. That's an incorrect
statement. I would say to you that uh it
is accepted that the King James version
talking about the King James English
some of the words are considered archaic
>> and you know we don't say thou and thee
and ye anymore but most people
understand those words. So when you say
archaic that means they're not spoken
that way anymore but you can easily find
out what these words mean today. But
there is one verse that does have a word
in there in the King James version that
should not be there. So speaking in
honesty, as we try to do here, we do
here at 3ABN is Acts 12:4. There's a
word that's a word that snuck in there
in the King James version. And I'll read
that to you. It says Acts 12:4. So when
he had arrested him, he put him in
prison and delivered him to four squads
of soldiers to keep him, intending to
bring him before the apostles after
Easter. It says in the King James
version, but the actual word is huh pak,
which means Passover.
>> Yes.
>> Which means Passover. And so that word
snuck in there, the Easter word. But um
you can compare with other versions and
find out that for example the New King
James Version doesn't use the word
Easter. It uses the word Passover
because that is a more accurate
translation. This is as far as I can go
with the limited time.
>> Wow. Beautiful. Thank you for that. Uh
recently my husband and I were at the
Museum of the Bible.
>> We just in Washington DC. Fascinating
>> and we learned a lot. We just didn't
have enough time. Speaking of time, we
are going to take a short break and
we're going to have a few closing
thoughts from our panelists. So, you
stay tuned and we will be right back.
>> If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
[Music]
Be sure to include your name and where
you live. And then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
Welcome back. I hope you were blessed. I
was. I always learned something new.
Anyway, we're going to give our
panelists a few closing thoughts and
we're going to start with Pastor John.
>> Very quickly, Pastor John Denzy made a
statement about the dead. And if you see
anybody or hear anybody that sounds or
looks like your loved one,
>> yeah,
>> that is what Jesus warned against in the
Old Testament in Leviticus 19:31.
Give no regard to mediums or familiar
spirits. And in three cases, Leviticus
20:6, Leviticus 20:27, and Leviticus
19:31, familiar spirits, demons have the
ability to appear in an apparition form,
and they know what your loved ones look
like. So, be careful. That's not your
loved one. That's a familiar spirit, and
that is evil.
>> Amen. Thank you,
>> thank you, Pastor Ryan.
>> Yes. Three of the questions that um I
answered today by God's grace took us to
the cross,
>> Gethsemane and the cross. And as we were
doing this, I realized that as we focus
on Calvary, not only are we reminded of
the infinite worth of Christ, but it
reminds us of the infinite worth he has
put upon us. So stay there at the foot
of the cross, friends, there is
salvation.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. I want to say something
about the Ethiopian Bible. Some of these
apocryphal books which are included are
the Mcabes, Ezra, Baroo. And so I would
say that if you're interested in reading
the Ethiopian Bible, it has some
historical value and it's good to
compare scriptures with scriptures. So I
would not totally discard it. But I
would not say that it's an original
Bible because it is not. It is a
translation.
>> Yes. Wow. Thank you all. The Lord was
praised through this wonderful study.
And I just want to leave a Bible text
with you. If you're going if you're
fearful of something in Isaiah 41:10, it
says, "Fear not, for I am with you. Be
do not not dismayed for I am your God. I
will strengthen you." Take that with
you. Amen. Have a blessed day in Jesus.
>> Amen.
[Music]